[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
we're [ __ ] dead uncle Joey uncle
Joey's been busy all day [ __ ] but
I'm here now
it's Friday get your [ __ ] together
[ __ ] slinging dick and giving
our [ __ ] kneepads
that's your motto for the day you know
I'm saying it's a beautiful day to be
alive I've been busy today make it move
some mill here a mill there well [ __ ] it
out we'd make time for my little church
family get together smoke a few tooth
roots look at this we have some Tahoe G
from perennial we got some [ __ ] that
perennial
we're going deep in the murky waters of
the world with you or without you so I'm
happy you [ __ ] tuned in we're gonna
open up with some [ __ ] stars of debt
here's the body of Christ compels you
that's two down
that's 400 milligrams
and that's six just opening night that's
only title sucking fire well if you done
with your [ __ ] like you understand me
I don't know how I'll know about it I
really don't give a [ __ ] I'm just trying
to explain to you [ __ ] it's
turned around [ __ ]
the body of Christ compels you
nutritious delicious and bam [ __ ] you
know I'm saying all I need is you
[ __ ] here I have two bags of
those I'm going deep this weekend leaves
in Boston easy be with mom with the [ __ ]
what kind of Jew does six out I was on a
plane he's [ __ ] Ziva is what I'm
talking about this is what I'm talking
about the priority and the youngsters
today hmm it's shot [ __ ] but
anyway who gives a [ __ ] about menus who
gives a [ __ ] about eating we're here to
do one thing nice to see the devil
together Illinois anyway
look at how I here who ate all of my
sorry ooh
aiyah but Joey enough with the [ __ ]
Specter ruin [ __ ] I gotta be in Spanish
I don't wanna know about I don't know no
more smoke briefing Joey that's it
enough with the chitty-chat we're about
to go deep of the murky waters of the
world
oh yeah
this is the [ __ ] that killed Prince
Kennedy and [ __ ] John Lennon Hoffman
but anyway who's talking about that I'm
talking about life the life all about me
to give you with this [ __ ] reefer a
dead great week this week you guys
bought him
[ __ ] it
azeema is knocking on the door but you
don't see me [ __ ] crying I did what I
had to do and now what the [ __ ] you hear
whistles every time I take a [ __ ] but
who gives a [ __ ] the most important
thing is I haven't tapped out yet it's
like digitorum power but what I tap out
[ __ ] no cuz I go all the way to the end
to the wheels fall off understand me
that's the point what America is nobody
wants to [ __ ] do not know that commit
to it focus on it I didn't do it like a
something good pull and do what you
gotta do is like me with this rhythm
it's not real I don't give a [ __ ]
Australia's movie diminished
we did the top now we're gonna try this
[ __ ] my applause that's an eyeball of
a [ __ ] Savage right there there's
some hardcore oh [ __ ] take the tour my
mind made up
come on you could get it get it girl any
time tonight is fine the [ __ ] you saying
Joey next thing you know you're singing
black people music you're jumping up and
down I don't know nothing
all I know is this Friday we're about to
go deep into the murky waters are the
end of the world you know what when I
get my [ __ ] breathing those operation
licked on to shape three [ __ ] inches
off that [ __ ] [ __ ] sniffing it's
getting bigger by the day the older you
get your nose grows he is grow you dick
don't grow that I don't get that let's
do this
Angelina man John and I passed our FINA
little Sicilian for you [ __ ] in
case I got some [ __ ] real dogs out
there
oh yeah well yeah
oh yeah smooth nice nice it tastes like
a Clint with swamp top and I like it I
like it
I'm so shoot you with [ __ ] Friday
[ __ ] take the stick out of your ass I
don't wanna hit by your Chris your
Christ and you [ __ ] Jesus it's over
everybody's looking to do one thing
tonight it's over
you popped on that what what are you
gonna do let's finish this bowl around
let you go on your merry well with Bobby
again for a few days you know I love you
I love you [ __ ] and everything
I got if it wasn't for you and that were
gods
[ __ ] my soldiers come with you
you with me I may want to be when I was
[ __ ] then [ __ ] them in the [ __ ]
meal they run upon it's over it's Friday
wash your [ __ ] shave your [ __ ] I
hope you had a good week with jonquil
Joey you know I love your [ __ ]
till the end and [ __ ] I don't like the
recipes fluff and I have approved aches
let's get together let's smoke reefers
do whatever the [ __ ] you want to do it's
Friday
be careful don't drink and drive and
that's it I love your mother [ __ ] to
see you Monday 8:00 o'clock we're gonna
rock it next week don't worry about that
we got secret weapons
we got Google of biscuits we got THC
crystal we got angel but we got
everything all right I'll see you next
week be safe uncle Joey loves you back